a social worker thinks she has rescued a
girl from her abusive parents but then
realizes that the girl is not as
innocent as she seems so today on cinema
recap i'll show you case 39 the film
begins with a woman named emily who
works as a social worker and has closed
a total of 38 cases her boss arrives and
gives her a new case case 39 the case
involves a girl named lilith who
misbehaves in class because she suffers
from domestic violence at home so the
social workers go to the girl's house to
talk to her parents about it however
lilly's parents have a very strange
behavior the mother never smiles and the
father does not even want to exchange a
word with emily then emily tells her
boss about the parents strange behavior
so her boss calls the couple in to talk
to them at the police station however
when they show up they seem like they
are great parents emily finds a way to
talk to lilith in private so she can see
if she's being mistreated at home
melilith responds that her parents hate
her and that she has even heard them say
they want to send her to hell then emily
asked a friend who is a police officer
to help her get the girl out of the
house because she believes that the
parents are planning to hurt her however
the policeman tells her that in order to
help her she has to show evidence that
the girl is in danger the next day emily
meets lilith at her school to give her
her phone number in case she ever feels
unsafe at home that night emily receives
a call from lilith who tells her that
she thinks her parents are planning
something bad but she ends up falling
asleep so emily calls her friend and
they both go to the girl's house to
verify that she's okay however when they
arrive they realize that the parents are
trying to kill lilith by putting her in
an oven so emily and the police enter
the house they fight the parents and
they save the little girl the couple was
put on trial where the judge orders a
psychiatric examination since it is
possible that their mental health is not
well this makes emily angry because she
believes that they should be in jail
meanwhile lilith is transferred to an
orphanage where she could find a new
family but she doesn't like living there
so she tells emily that she wants to
live with her and although emily at
first refuses she ends up asking her
boss for an authorization to take
custody for the girl until the orphanage
finds a family for her emily takes the
girl home and takes good care of her the
next day her work sends her to lilith's
old house and as she's exploring she
sees a lock on her parents bedroom as if
they were afraid that someone would
break in meanwhile we see a child that
is in therapy because he has problems
with his behavior he seems to be a quiet
child who loves his parents a lot this
child is in a group therapy with lilith
and other children with a psychologist
who is also emily's co-worker emily
picks lilith up from therapy and takes
her home then the next day when emily
goes to work her boss tells her that the
child who was in therapy killed his
parents the night before emily goes to
the crime scene and talks to the boy but
he seems to be very sorry for what he's
done and he even cries emily is confused
at this as she doesn't know why the
child would do such a thing so she talks
to her co-worker the psychologist but he
tells her to not let it bother her the
next day emily is chilling at home and
suddenly realizes that lilith has a
photo that belongs to her as she was
looking through her things emily doesn't
get angry at this but she tells lilly
that the lady in the photo is her mother
that she died in a car accident however
when she finishes talking to lilith
emily takes her personal things and puts
them in a locked room so lilith cannot
touch them again the next day emily goes
to eat with her friend the policeman
there through the newspaper she realizes
that lilly's parents were declared crazy
and will probably be transferred to a
psychiatric care then the policeman
tells emily that the night the child
killed his parents he had received a
call from emily's house but emily tells
the policeman that she did not call him
so they both come to the conclusion that
maybe lilith is the one who made the
call emily and the policemen talked to
lilith and asked her if she had any
contact with the boy that night but lily
tells him that she did not call anyone
and emily seems to believe her but the
policeman doesn't the next day emily
asked the boy who called him that night
however when emily asked this the boy
begins to feel frightened and even has
problems breathing so he's transferred
to the hospital where the boy confirms
to emily that someone called him but it
was a man that same day lilith has a
session with a psychologist he asked her
what is her worst fear and lilith answer
is that she will tell him what she is
afraid of only if he answers the
question first so the psychologist then
tells lilith that he is afraid of bees
and lilith tells him that she is afraid
of herself
since she has bad thoughts about people
and even confesses that she has bad
thoughts involving him after talking
about the thoughts she warns him that he
should worry about what is to come as if
she's threatening him so the
psychologist gets scared and confused by
the behavior of the girl he tells emily
what happened then goes home when he
arrives he begins to receive strange
calls with weird sounds suddenly he
starts to feel discomfort in one of his
ears and after examining himself he
finds a bee he throws it into the toilet
but then more and more be start to come
out from his ears and other parts of his
body making him go crazy until he ends
up killing himself then emily attends
the funeral and she begins to feel that
something is wrong with lilith because
she remembers that the psychologist told
her that he felt threatened by her emily
then begins to investigate and finds a
video recording where lilith's mother
says that her and her husband used to
have brothers but when lilith was born
they began to die one by one and she
blames the girl saying that she is the
incarnation of evil the mother also says
that she could not get rid of her until
lilith found someone new and this makes
emily feel very scared emily decides to
go see lilly's parents at the clinic
however the nurse tells her that the
mother has gone crazy because she
scratches her own skin so emily has no
choice but to talk to the father instead
he tells her about lilith and that she
is not his daughter but an old
destructive soul like a demon that she
feeds off the goodness of people he
warns her that she is going to hurt her
using her worst fear against her emily
gets scared at this and when she gets
home she starts to put away all the
important papers and phones and any
objects that lilith could use to hurt
her
leaving only a knife to defend herself
with at that moment lilith arrives from
school and begins to ask why the phones
are gone and emily says that they broke
down then we see that lilith is
suspicious of the situation the next day
emily asked the orphanage if they have
found a family for lilly but the manager
tells her that not yet and that for now
emily has to take responsibility of her
because she was the one who promised to
take care of her emily has no choice but
to continue taking care of lilith
so she goes to pick her up from a
therapy session with a psychologist
and when she arrives she sees that
lilith is whispering things into a
girl's ear emily thinks that she is
putting strange ideas into her head so
angrily she pulls lilith away from the
other girl the psychologist seeing this
scolds emily from mistreating the girl
but lilith says it's okay then on the
way to the elevator emily tells lilith
that she will not be returning to those
sessions because she does not want her
to be around other children lilith gets
angry at this and tells emily are you
sure
and suddenly emily can feel that the
elevator is broken and when it's about
to crash to the ground everything goes
back to normal and the elevator's door
is open emily gets even more scared so
she decides to go see her friend the
police to tell him everything hoping
that he can help her however he doesn't
believe her and he only tells her that
it's all in her head and that none of it
is real so emily has no choice but to
protect herself she puts locks in her
room
but lilith realizes this emily locks
herself in the room and takes a
screwdriver for self-defense
at night as it's raining outside and
there's a thunderstorm lilith knocks on
her door saying that she is afraid but
emily does not want to open the door so
she just ignores her however lilith
begins to knock louder and louder on the
door yelling at her to let her in emily
get scared and when it seemed that the
girl was gone suddenly emily sees a
monster coming out of her closet so she
runs out of the house she runs down the
street and sees a bus driver and asks
for help but he tells her that no one is
chasing her and when emily turns to the
street she doesn't see any monster so
she just walks away without knowing
where to go she decides to get in her
car and try to escape but lilith is in
the backseat and tells her that she must
never leave her alone and that from now
on she has to obey everything she says
so emily begins to cry out of
desperation and fear the next day she
sees lilith's father again but this time
she asked him how to get rid of the girl
the man replies that she must kill her
but this can only be done while she's
sleeping although lilith rarely sleeps
emily then goes to the policeman again
and asks for help and this time he
believes her and even offers to help
kill the girl so emily goes home to look
for lilith while the policeman gets a
gun however when the officer leaves a
police station with a gun he sees that a
bunch of dogs are growling at him when
he gets in his car he discovers that
there is a dog in the car waiting for
him and it bites him in the neck so the
policeman tries to shoot it with the gun
but he fails and ends up shooting
himself emily receives a call letting
her know that the officer died at this
emily gets really angry and demands
lilith to leave her house however lilith
answers with a demon voice that she must
never yell at her again emily gets
scared and runs through her room and
covers the door with everything she can
find the lilith begins to bang on the
door with such force that it knocks it
down so emily runs to hide under her bed
lilith approaches her slowly so emily
asks what she wants the girl replies
that she only wants her love so emily
tells her that she can love her if she
doesn't hurt her that night emily
prepares coffee for lilith and crushes
sleeping pills to give it to her then
when she is asleep she starts to pour
gasoline in the house and burns the girl
alive however when she leaves she
realizes that lilith is outside as well
then both emily and lilith get in the
car driving without a destination lilith
then tells emily that she finally knows
what she is afraid of being like her
mother because apparently she was a
woman who hated herself and also hated
her own daughter then emily looks at
herself in the rearview mirror as she is
transforming into her mother and she can
barely keep a grip on driving
as if she was going to have a car
accident just like her mother however
emily begins to say that none of this is
true until everything finally returns to
normal and now lilith is the one who
gets scared at that moment emily turns a
car towards a lake then she fights a
demon underwater until she manages to
lock him in emily finally comes to the
surface safe and sound and looks into
the water and sees bubbles she can
finally rest
the end if you liked the video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving the recaps of the best horror
movies my name is tc and i'll see you in
the next video goodbye